a lingering painful death for a pair of
dogs police confirmed that two young
dogs died of heat exhaustion over the
weekend at a home
no tropicana and rainbow their own are
now arrested facing cruelty charges
madison kimbrough has the neighbor's
reaction and what pet owners are
required to do
during times of excessive heat
we've had multiple dogs that have
already died in the last few weeks in
this extreme
heat and anyone that would keep them in
the garage
you know it's just unfathomable
on monday animal control found two pit
bulls dead inside of a southwest valley
garage
the dogs died a horrible death due
to be locked up in a hot
probably airless garage no food no water
is even worse
and i have no idea how long they were in
there thirty-year-old aisha hill owned
the dogs she's facing two counts of
animal abuse
according to police reports one of the
dogs had cuts on its snout
police believe it was trying to dig into
the concrete floor to find
cooler air i just think that it's just
unfair neighbor carson mitma owns a
six-year-old pitbull named bullet
he says the breed already goes through
so much so this hits close to home
pit bulls and themselves have like have
to come out of this hole of like you
know being seen as these dog fighting
dogs but in reality you know they're
probably some of the sweetest dogs that
i know
animal activists hope that this case
brings up felony charges with that lady
we were glad to see that someone was
held accountable madison kimbrough 8
news now
here in las vegas a new ordinance says
when it is hotter than 105 degrees pet
owners
must provide some sort of cooling like
fans or misters and it's a good idea to
do that when it just gets hot in general
christian